good morning everyone we're excited to
get started talking about
how to find inspiration from the most
unlikely places um before we begin
one general frame that we'd like to
establish i mean
we gotta warm up a little bit we are a
little cold we are so cold
okay um how about a quick uh practice we
preach a quick one word
story you know one word proverb kind of
thing okay quick improv warm-up
all right always learn how
to make something out of
nothing all right yes yes yes okay
perfect great feel warmer i don't know
about you i feel warm thank you
okay so one thing that we know
is when we talk about innovation there
are lots of kinds of legitimate
um types of innovation one is
incremental innovation making a product
or service better
faster cheaper more affordable
and what we see is that that doesn't
require getting very far
out of orbit we like to say for an
intact team in an organization
if you think about the team and what
they know getting to incremental
innovation just requires a low orbit
and it's it's valuable and it helps the
organization
but disruptive innovation one of the
things we focus on to d-school is a
different thing
and often requires getting much farther
out of orbit
and what we see is that teams are really
great at bringing ideas in for a landing
but the problem is that sometimes they
have they have difficulty actually
launching into a high enough orbit that
it's actually worth bringing it in for a
landing
and so we want to talk today about how
not incremental innovation but how as an
intact team
to routinely
receive the inspiration required to
deliver breakthrough innovation
so um this tool came out why we
developed analogous or why we work so
hard on it is we've
we saw a difference come out of doing
programs with open programs you call
them where we mix up teams and we have
people from really diverse backgrounds
we found it was easier to get into that
orbit meaning if i'm not in your
industry i can come up with wild ideas
for you
but when we put the teams together and
stick with an industry
we found that they'd inevitably stay a
little bit closer to home
a little bit safer they they couldn't
get out of their own way
they get an insight from a customer but
not be able to to
take it to a new place outside the
industry so this is the idea with
using analogy and the power of analogy
is to get into a higher orbit
so the question really is for intact
teams inside of organizations
how do we launch into a higher orbit so
we want to tell the story of a
company that we've worked with a lot
over the last few years called fairchild
semiconductor
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
with fairchild they're basically the
grandfather of silicon valley
they're founded by william shockley who
invented the transistor
and they attracted an amazing group of
people who
have gone on to found many of the most
storied organizations in silicon valley
the fairchild over the last few years
realized something
about their business they realized that
increasingly they have really really
large customers
and they um they were hearing from small
customers that they
weren't getting the kind of service and
the experience that they wanted to get
and so they asked us we teach human
centered design so they asked us hey can
you guys come in and help us talk to
small
customers about their needs and about
how we could interact with them better
so we came in thinking it's all about
understanding small customers better and
working with them to teaching them
mostly the empathy tools we teach in the
school
when they came in one thing that that we
heard which was really surprising is
that there's all sorts of confusion
around
when am i going to receive a product i
place an order for a product
you tell me this time sometimes it comes
early sometimes it comes late
but i don't really know from
face-to-face interviews with their
actual customer right
so they brought in a bunch of customers
into the room they mixed up a bunch of
teams from fairchild from sales and
product and engineering and basically
said let's try to understand
and um one thing that they that started
becoming a theme was
i don't know whether i'm gonna get the
product and when i'm gonna get it
and so that was that became a big
surprise
and um we actually had the teams go
through a process of kind of distilling
some of the conversations they had had
and focusing on what we call a point of
view statement so we want to share one
of the four or five points of view that
they came up with but one of the points
of view was
we met a technology director at a small
but high profile important customer
we were amazed to realize that the
routine disruptions that just
they're just an annoyance to big
customers they threatened to kill small
customers and threaten to put them out
of business entirely
they talked to one small customer who
said last year i
almost missed my quarter because of a
two dollar part that was on back quarter
and i kept thinking i was gonna get the
two dollar part and it kept taking
longer and longer
and so i ended up needing to place a
backup order and so uh the executives
from fairchild said you know would be
game-changing
it would be game-changing if we could
make this person and this and small
customers like this person
confident enough in our delivery
estimates that they stop placing backup
orders yep
and so that was a big aha for the for
the companies
because what they know is in the
semiconductor industry there's really
very little clarity around inventory
levels
and supply forecasts because there's so
many parts and because there's so many
fabrication facilities
and so many distributors and the network
is so complex
there's very little understanding even
internally inside the company what
actual inventory levels are
and so to actually go so far as to make
customers
confident in delivery estimates
really felt like a bold and provocative
ambition not just for fairchild but
really for the industry at large
and so that's that's a that's what they
distilled from these interactions
so at this stage we sort of keying up
the example with analogous so they
they did these interviews face-to-face
they came up with these um
amazing that word kill i think was from
the actual user saying this
this ends my business if you don't
deliver but they're stuck saying what do
we do next
you know that's that's great we have
thousands of these small customers
versus a handful of these huge customers
and are we sort of thinking about the
big customers because that's where
essentially the dollars are but this is
amazing information
so now they think what could we do as
opposed to getting to ideas they've
never imagined
right so enter sort of an an approach
with analogous so again they have a need
that's inspired by their actual customer
they've actually interviewed their
customers
they've decided on that and now they
want to get to new new places
so the same old brainstorm isn't going
to launch this this is actually i think
roughly a quote i don't understand how
we're going to use news and we're going
to tell some stories at the end about
this because
we've failed getting here but um they
couldn't get to new space so think about
everybody's in the same industry
everybody's thinking what could we
possibly do
they start off on that foot now we get
out of the building
right so it's one thing to see a new
need it's another thing to think of new
ideas once you see anything
and so this is where we want to
introduce this idea of analogous
inspiration so
we taught this technique to the company
and they ended up doing some pretty cool
things so we want to brag on them and
then we'll give a couple of other
examples as well
but basically what they did is they use
this technique and they ended up going
to a flower shop of all places
it's a little surprising but they first
went to a flower shop instead
they went to the flower shop because
they they they thought about now places
think of that need that that routine
disruptions kill a business
so they thought of a bunch and we're
going to tell you sorry they thought
flower shops
flowers go bad they will they've got to
have inventory problems how do they deal
with that what if
the you know what if the public's not
there at the certain time when the roses
are there or the
they don't they haven't timed it right
or the supply so that's why they chose a
flower shop
what they learned is pretty interesting
they basically learned that they in
talking to this little shopkeeper
they said hey how do you know if you're
going to have enough roses for next week
how do you know
whether this stuff is going to stay on
your shelf long enough for people for it
to be fresh when people want to buy it
and she just showed him her computer she
said oh it's really cool actually
not only do i see my suppliers inventory
and how many days they've had the
product
i can actually go click all the way
through the farmer and i can see the
farmer's inventory levels and i can see
when the farmer cut
the product and so they were just they
were basically amazed that the levels
of systems visibility this
small shop owner had between even
vendors between
people that shouldn't they wouldn't
consider talking to yeah so they also
they ended up going to a hotel as well
oh sorry so they said our industry never
tells customers actual delivery times
right
this flower shop owner gets a literal
estimate
from the farmer about when i cut it how
long it will be good for and the
distributor is transparent about all
that
but in this in the semiconductor
industry they realize that their
standard practices
they deliver an industry average which
is standard in the industry right it was
it was
what they learned growing up in the
semiconductors right it's going to take
roughly 14 days and whether it's only
one or whether it's 200
we know the average is 14. so that's
what we say
so they also went to a hotel because
they said who else kind of deals with
these kinds of problems and they thought
wow
somebody who arrives at a hotel really
late at night for example a hotel
the worst thing is to have an empty room
right just like an airline you never
want an mcc
so they always over book right they
oversell that's kind of common knowledge
that that
that industry does that so they said
they said they wanted to understand
how does a hotel deal with when somebody
shows up late they've already given
their room away
what do they do how do they handle this
person who says hey
i bought a room but we don't have a room
and they learned something really
interesting they actually went down to i
think it was a hyatt hotel they went
down to the front desk and they started
talking with
one of the check-in clerks they ask hey
what happens in this situation
she said oh it's easy first i look at
the other heights in the area
and i see what their inventory levels
are like they said you can do that she
said oh yeah just click right here and i
see all 15 of the hotels in our area and
i can see
which ones have availability she said if
they don't i can click through we have
relationships with
and rattled off a bunch of other hotel
companies names and said
we have relationships with them and i
can see all of their inventory levels
they said so say i come in late at night
and hyatt doesn't have a room what do
you do she said
i'll just walk them down the street to
the hilton or to the marriott or
wherever they have room
and that blew their minds right that
really surprised them
because she had an ability to see not
only her
company's inventory but other companies
inventory
and so they again it kind of building on
this realization
that for for them for fairchild their
hope is that a customer would come to
them and they'd have their products but
they
had never it never even dawned on them
to think wow maybe a competitor might
have a product which could meet our
customers
as well and we wouldn't have thought to
send them because maybe they'd like to
probably better or something like that
and what they realized from this hotel
clerk is no that breeds loyalty
if i make sure you have a room you're
coming back to me next time you aren't
going
i may have to check you into a hilton
but next time you're coming back to the
hype because we treated you so well yeah
and they were really amazing they
basically said you know what if we did
things differently
what if like the flower shop clerk or
like the uh hotel
front desk check-in what if we treated
inventory visibility and our
relationships with competitors
the snapshots so the fairchild team goes
out they they they've
interviewed their customers for a day
let's make the pictures every other
customer say end of a long day they're
inspired by this problem but also know
they can't get anywhere right
they go out and see they saw other
venues these are the ones we wanted to
cover they're sort of
because they're really unexpected i
think sushi chefs yeah and
you know the attitude of the team going
out was kind of like well what are we
going to learn
is this what do you know what could we
because there's still the mindset but
what's interesting was
they came back saying what if we
actually did things differently because
they were in spot again just
drilling down they were inspired by
seeing somebody else so effortlessly
like flip a screen around in the floral
shop and say this is this is
normal for us we deal with this problem
every day flowers go bad and storms
happen or
the greenhouse breaks or it happens all
the time so i've got to know
where i can't you know merchandise my
window i'm out of business so they're
inspired to say what if we do things
differently so
fast forward the insight was kind of
around tr they got a lot of
ideas about how to approach this right
so around transparency
around speed around almost an attitude
of hospitality
that i think they had but they never
thought they had such a range to
implement right okay
well the the the underlying thing is
just because this problem is new to us
doesn't mean it's new to the world and
we realize this is a problem but there
are lots of people who deal with this
problem all the time
yep so this provoked their ideation and
prototyping to the point that we're
going to jump ahead so
this is a solution which we think is
fabulous and they were kind enough to
show we can't talk about numbers it is
successful financially
they didn't want us to talk about the
numbers at fairchild but this is their
internal website so customers log into
this
it you can see the parts listed and you
can see active inventory numbers now
which is which is you
was unique and not currently um it would
show projected lead times it would show
projections of what might happen as
opposed to actually what they're going
to promise and what they think is going
on which is completely different
there were some things i left out of
this which was the ability for customers
even to create a virtual scenario
that they could say you know if i needed
this much how much what would happen as
opposed to having a direct sales
transaction so they brought back in this
attitude i think of transparency
that we're gonna um actually what if we
gave our customers the agency
as i think that floor shop the agency to
make a decision to go with this lead
time or not go with it
but an attitude is funny talking to the
leadership there about
we really do now understand or think
about it differently that if the
customers gets what they need
it's it's going to work out in the end
right which for them was different as
opposed to saying i've got to keep the
customer with fairchild so whatever that
takes
i want to hold on to it now the attitude
is even if they circle away like the
hyatt exactly hotel example we know
they're going to come back because this
is a terrific experience for them
right we want our customer to get the
product not we want our customers to
stay right here
yeah that's great let's tell one more
example really quickly shall we
yeah we can't get enough all right so
unexpectedly i'll
cue this one up this is a really
interesting company um out of new
zealand
is the sealord which is um um
a fishing company they're the second
largest in new zealand really
interesting ownership structure they're
owned half by miori so
half by indigenous tribes and um
they have a very strong look them up on
the internet very strong
and clear point of view about
sustainable fishing
terrific people you remember we were
nice enough to work with them and uh we
work with a team there
let me think about this they they came
up with an insight around
um they interviewed customers so similar
to the fair shot they had interviewed
customers and they
they got to this deep insight around
products as they
they tend to distribute products through
retailers so it's a supermarket they're
not in the us i think in a big way but
they're in australia in a big way in
asia in a big way they'll distribute to
a grocery chain
when they have this technological
innovation right yeah that they could
they could fish for a certain type of
fish i guess that was the framing is
this fish called hokie
and then what's it called an ev called
hokey hoki in
new zealand and called blue grenadine
blue grenadier in other parts of the
world
it was kind of a commodity fish and one
of their challenges was we don't know
what to do with this we can fish it
sustainably we have this technology
so we feel like we can maintain our
fisheries and get this great great fish
but
it's not been ever too popular right so
they took that as a given well they were
kind of biased themselves even as a team
because hokie in new zealand
is it's it's kind of a cheap fish yeah
and people don't really like it people
go for it more exciting
they made it into fish sticks as i
recall or something so it wasn't there
but they said wow we have this amazing
competitive advantage we could do
something but yet we don't really know
what sort of makes people buy fish in a
way or
or or have a more of a premium
relationship with a brand they got to an
insight around what makes people commit
to buying a certain brand is a deep
sense of trust
um embassy in the history and there's
something there so there's some
nostalgia
so with that that point of view was
essentially that was their point of view
was
given this insight we've talked to
customers that's the insight around this
sense of nostalgia
how do we actually do that and that's
where they couldn't get out of their own
way so enter
um heading out in the field now to do
some analogous um
locations they went to of all places
it's actually their team boards you can
see they actually went through the same
process
and one of the fair challenges and you
see that vertical as the points of view
so jumping ahead they went out in the
field and uh in new zealand was in
auckland
in a britamart i think it's called the
it's a downtown area
and they went to a tea shop they're
really cool looking t2
and they actually had an experience uh
purchasing tea
and it was so simple but they they
decided they wanted to visit other
places that dealt with commodity
products products that
you know t is their their thought going
in was tsp right
so they got to know something about our
challenge what they came out is
in this shop you can mix your own tea so
you go to the counter you can say i
prefer a little bit of this a little bit
a little bit that flavor and they'll
even tell you at the end of the
experience
if it's good let me have a sip of that
if it's good um we'll put your name on
it and actually start selling it
as a mixture so they turned it into this
whole experience and the
amazing ones they left incredibly
inspired that
they could change the retail experience
around it right and even through
distributors as
the tea companies were right yeah one of
one of their big insights was there's
something about telling a story around a
product which
can transform it from a commodity that
you get anywhere to
it's almost de-prioritizing the
commercial element of the transaction
and making it more of an experience more
of a story and bringing almost a sense
of romance to it
yeah so what they actually did is they
started saying how how could we tell a
story around
hokie and how could we actually bring a
sense of romance to that fish
and what they ended up doing is pretty
cool they said wow the the new zealand
market there's already such a strong
perception of hokie
that we don't we we feel like it'd be
really difficult to affect that
perception but
we're about to launch a major effort in
australia
what if we did that differently what if
we repossession the launch there so
they're in the process of negotiations
with a big retailer in australia and
they said
instead of the kind of instead of
offering them a
menu of fixed options that they normally
would around fish sticks and frozen fish
and things like that they're calling it
and calling it blue grenadier as they do
in that market what if we said no no
this is special
and they really saw that what the tea
company did well is they made it
fancy and special using story what if we
told the story
of this amazing technology and this
amazing fish and it's msc certified it's
this amazing thing what if we told a
story
not to be end customer in this case but
to the retailer so that they got
inspired by the romance and the
possibility of this fish
and they ended up doing something pretty
cool they ended up as you can see here
in the supermarket in australia it's now
a branded
offering so it's sealer it's the only
brand in the fresh fish
aisle so if you think about the counter
ordinarily when i go to the grocery
store
i can just only see fish i don't see
brands the picture they just set up such
as amazing right
so not only do you see the fish there
but you actually see there's a banner
which is a branded banner and it's all
about hokie it's not blue grenadier
it's hokey but it's but the story that
they were able to
inspire the retailer with is one of
sustainability
and one of uh surety of supply it's a
really big deal to retailers to know
we can always get this fish and they
knew because of their technological
innovation
we can guarantee fish that's fresher
than any of your fisheries in australia
can deliver it
and we can make sure it's younger it's
higher quality it's fresher fish
and we and you can always have it and
they now are able to charge a premium
over 2x what they what
the other fish in the same counter is
which is the same fish
and the retail as a partner in that
which i love the story is you know
there's two people involved and it's
also a story that
this is a business that's kind of they
thought like distributors they thought
we
we catch the fish we by the by the pound
we sell it by the pound we make money
here they said well actually there's a
why are we giving ourselves such a small
playing field by looking at something
else
they could actually get some inspiration
right and they said that now it's it's
even informed how they think about
moving into other parts of asia where
the fish is unknown
whereas currently they might just pursue
a strategy of expanding their current
product offering
they're radically rethinking how do they
enter the market maybe it's about
bringing whole
fresh fish into the market instead of
boxed frozen fish yeah
but it's transformed the way they're
thinking about new markets when they
bring the lens of
how do we tell a story to make something
special versus what did we
kind of buy our own cultural defaults
what do we think the thing is
very cool so let's go and let's actually
back up and
and go through we'll we'll use the
fairchild example but we'll go through
how to do this
and sort of the you know the and give
you a couple tips at the end
so for you if you're kind of wondering
now okay it's all well and good that
semiconductor companies and
fishing companies can do it how do i do
it we're going to talk now about how
step by step you can actually seek
obvious inspiration yourself
great so with design process and what we
teach at the d school
you start with a con you find a consumer
needs so like you've gone out you've
you've spent time and immersed with your
users and you found a need so in the
case of the semiconductors they found
this thing about there was real pain
with their customers
around not only that the tactical like
you're out of stuff and that hurts me
the fear of that happening was even the
bigger thing right that's the need they
found this fear
um with the users for fish they felt
unless they have a trust and story and
there's no there's no romance the fish
counter it really is just looking at
prices and looking and
asking the person behind the counter
which they get so
given you have that how to do the
analogous
inspiration is think of possible
locations visit the locations and apply
it
so let's go through that in the case so
in terms of the um
think of possible analysis locations
what happens with the example of
um fairchild is they they had this need
right so they brainstormed
what are other venues and locations
where routine
disruptions kill a business that's how
they came up with huh a flower shop they
didn't know for sure but they thought
right pretty clear if flowers go bad or
if something hap there's a storm
someplace and they can't get something
you know that's if you don't get
poinsettias in in this country at
christmas that could be a problem
right so that's what they thought of
they thought of venues like that
right the the big thing here is it's not
benchmarking yeah
you're not looking at competitors within
the industry and saying how are they
solving this problem
it's articulating the problem in such a
way that it causes you to look
for places of inspiration which are
wholly unexpected nobody in a
semiconductor company would think that i
could learn something from a flower shop
owner yeah this guy's making you know
he's selling
it's orders of magnitude different in
terms of the product and the scale and
all that stuff
and yet when they realize oh it's about
disruption actually hurting the business
i can learn from really unexpected
places yep so not benchmarking
but seeing the problem in such a way
that you're able to see
unexpected places as a source of
inspiration because they're solving the
same problem
in some other way so in the case of
fairchild
what they did is they said hey this
bottom line especially be game changing
to make him confident enough in our
delivery estimates he stops placing
backup orders
the question is who else is doing that
who is making people confident that they
still keep purchasing
and and where and in the middle spot
there that we were amazed to realize
where else is this reality of
supply dramatically impacting and
possibly putting out us out of business
where is it felt immediately and
regularly and how
and how are they dealing with that
because maybe we can learn from them
so this what we talked about took half
an hour
right now to brainstorm those things we
come up with a list and then
what's important here and there's
immediacy we'll talk about right away
in both cases we left immediately so
we've spent time with the user we focus
on this thing we brainstorm those
locations
leave and visit the locales and you you
sort of um
take a look at how they do it in their
context and i think this is something we
talk a lot about with empathy
as we do design thinking is having a
beginner mindset
not diving right into tactical hey you
run the flower shop tell me how you deal
with your inventory it's like tell me
about how
you know when was the last time you sort
of had a run on
roses or you had to run on and let them
talk to you about how they manage it and
story after story comes out but that it
wasn't a tactical like
show me the actual that we talk a bit
about the technology and the monitoring
is that that breakthrough but there was
a whole story of sort of
an interaction yeah i think i'm talking
about how their business works
yeah absolutely so how they did that if
your child so
you visit and you go out and the way
they did is they actually
picked a couple of locations and then
they went out in pairs
and then they prepared interview
questions which are really loose which
are really open-ended
uh so that they could learn something
that maybe they don't already know so
this is an example question tell me
about how you handled the last time you
were short on something
but as barry said all of a sudden it
starts a conversation
that then that maybe gives a line of
sight into operations or practices or
policies or technologies
which support getting around the problem
that they just realized that they had
yep so then apply it back so third stage
simple apply it back so they got this
insight around
transparency or insight around trusting
your vendors and being more open
they would immediately apply that and
say what would that mean in our context
so as you take it to the next one in
their point of view
they literally said to us now back into
the world of semiconductors
how might we actually use transparency
to change the way we deal with our
smaller customers they took that last
statement that it would be game changing
too
and then took some of the things that
they realized by going
to the flower shop like wow would be
game changing to make him confident
how does flower shop do it by giving
visibility into actual inventory levels
across the entire supply chain
how does the hotel do it this other
posted here by connecting with a
substitute competitors product if we're
out of stock
these are ways that other people do it
it's not it's not that they take the
house specifically but they bring that
how back into the context of the
semiconductor problem
and there's the final one yeah and so
finally this is the one that they
actually used
as as a way to reframe how they thought
about delivering
the breakthrough for the small customers
so
again the empathy want to sort of
separate empathy they in both cases they
did empathy directly with their
customers to focus the team on something
and focus them on
on a need that mattered in the fish
industry again it was this idea that
history
and nostalgia and story mattered to
people they understood that but what
they needed help with was
getting inspiration from outside getting
fresh ideas that are outside of the
in this one case the fish industry in
the other case the semiconductor
industry and getting to new places
in terms of addressing the opportunity
all right so three closing comments and
then
and then we'll open it up for questions
so maybe the self-diagnosis
the idea is one thing we'd suggest
is intact teams um
that you feel like were if jeremy and i
were brainstorming for a new course for
example we might say
we'd love to have an outsider in that
brainstorm we'd love to have some new
energy or we'd use a technique like
analogous
to get to new places i think there's a
self-diagnosis that's realizing
i guess one thing i would say if there's
not a lot of energy you're not very
generative as a team
this is a great technique if you if you
have a sense of that the insight with
your customer something you feel is
worth worth
charging forward and actually solving
this can help actually give you energy
and new directions second thing that we
wanted to say is kind of a mia culpa
sequencing matters we had originally
when we we prototype all the tools that
we teach
and we originally taught this tool we
actually felt
it was an empathy tool and it meaning it
was a tool that should come earlier in
terms of learning more about
needs and we worked on a project with a
big consumer packaged goods company
and we sequenced it way up front in the
design process that we teach here at the
d-school
and it flopped big time it really
flopped
right very because we realized it wasn't
we we found that the teams were kind
of they were locking their gears and
they were by going out and
going to analogous integration or going
to analogous locations to gain empathy
it it sent the teams to solve a bunch of
problems that actually weren't your user
wasn't anymore right they didn't
focus on something that matters and so
we want to say even for us it's
something that it's kind of been in fits
and starts where we're designing how to
figure it out
but it's really important perry's
mentioned this a couple times you need
to have a
a unique understanding of your customer
you need to have a unique
way of thinking about your customers
problem that is
rooted in their need not in your
business problem not in the challenge
you face but in the challenge they face
and then if you have that and we think
that it's great to get that from a
primary interaction by actually talking
to them not reading some market research
or a focus group but actually talking to
real customers
tools we teach in other classes but then
once you've got that
then once you focus and synthesize what
you've learned from those conversations
then it's a great opportunity to use
analogous inspiration because
as we've said seeing a new problem isn't
enough for an intact team you need to
see no problem but then you also need to
think of new ideas
and analogous integration is a really
great way to think of new ideas
other there are other great ways too
right you can mix up the team as you
said you can
seek outside inspiration you can get
different functions and departments
together
but one thing that you can do is seeking
analogous inspiration
after you've got that new unique frame
and then the last thing is immediately
applying
we've seen all too many organizations
enjoy the process of seeking inspiration
and so they go out and they look for
inspiration and then they think
they declare victories they say wow
there's people do it really interesting
ways isn't that great
but they don't actually go kind of the
last mile so to speak
and say and contextualize that
remarkable
solution into their own environment into
their own industry
and inspiration just for the sake of
inspiration we feel
does not yield disruptive innovation we
think about
innovation as as bob sutton says all the
time right creativity plus
implementation
yeah and this inspiration piece is great
for creativity but the last thing is you
have to implement if you want to do
something
that's disruptive in your industry with
your company you have to actually go
that last mile
and figure out how to bring that wild
disruptive solution from some other
context back into your context
so in both of these cases what that
meant was after
i mean it's a tiring day right they've
done empathy in this case here both one
day but
they go in the field and they gain
inspiration there's actually a bit of
work to do when they when they'd come
back as a team
we'd say no no get together and actually
like build a quick mock-up build a quick
prototype so remember the
um sealord example tired as they were we
said no no you'll lose it you have to
actually what would it mean to have a
story and they sort of i think they
wrote kind of a manifesto they
brainstorm a little bit they quickly
sort of mock something up
but it got them to turn the idea into
their context
not just leave it as that was really
interesting and exciting maybe we will
wouldn't it be interesting if right
bring it back and actually apply it
all right so with that uh the last thing
we'll say this is actually a tool from
the innovation at work
uh module on ideation but one thing we'd
say is starting small is okay if it
feels like a herculean task
to interview customers and to learn what
their needs are and then
to synthesize those interviews and then
brainstorm where analogous locations are
simple tools are really helpful this is
the analogy tool we just wanted to tip
our hat to it but
if you want to just explore a little bit
of what it looks like to actually
seek analogous inspiration one thing you
can think about if we walk through this
tool super quickly
it's think of analogous situations so
the first question is what's with the
emotion you're trying to evoke
so in the fairchild example it's the
sense of confidence
that that that the buyer the customer
feels confident in what we're telling
them right
then the question is who what or where
does that well who
conveys a sense of confidence well and
brainstorm four or five or six of
those things right so who who makes
people feel confident
a coach personal trainer oh yeah
personal trainer thinking of like a
suit tailor or something like that right
so then you bring that over to the right
side you say
what might a personal coach create for
the for these small customers that makes
them
feel confident in their estimates well
let's go personal workout program
right you know but yeah you bring them
into your community you have them
track their progress but it's new but
you can see how as soon as you bring
a different lens onto the problem it
immediately thinks
it helps you think about the problem
differently and so this is kind of a
great exercise that you can
just apply to any problem you face ask
yourself what's the emotion you're
trying to evoke
ask yourself who evokes that emotion not
who solves this problem in my industry
but what are
wildly unexpected places to do and then
bring it back into your problem
statement
and ask what would how would they solve
it if i brought a personal trainer and
to think about this problem
what are the kinds of things that they'd
be throwing out there it's a simple way
to bring the spirit of analogous
inspiration into your meetings today
so i've been looking aside a couple
questions that have come up one of them
is
what's the how many venues you've been
talking about they and when we tell
stories we tend to tell them like this
was the they went to a floral shop and
they went here and then they got the
inside
they went to um i would say half a dozen
or at least or more yeah they split up
as a team they went to those and they
went to see
um we were in san francisco they went to
the ferry terminal because they were
curious what happens when the weather is
there and they can't go on the tour
about alcatra like how do you deal with
weather problems they went to bike
rental places they went i mean
i forgot all the places yeah
we told those because it was a little
crisper to tell but um
i think each group spent about an hour
and a half out and they saw maybe
five or six venues and some yield things
some don't and they just keep rolling
through
right right um the other question i
think is interesting to ask is we've
told two stories about
um sort of professionals and part of our
work here we also work with students and
i think this is a
been a great tool applying it to student
work as well
i recom i recall chuckling because it
was a funny example of last year we had
a couple student teams that were stuck
in a leadership class we teach and we
literally um put in an envelope a couple
analogous locations we brainstormed for
them
and had an uber and we just sent them
out during the class period to get
unstuck do you recall that
yeah oh yeah let them do a con i think
they were doing something around sharing
so we went
sent to some new commune right and a
couple other places to to basically gain
inspiration and get unstuck
right and it's fun if you frame it
almost as a secret mission and that's
something that you know
as you think about leading a team as a
design challenge
designing the experience for the team
right maybe you get a secret envelope
that's going to self-destruct and
you you you have brainstormed a couple
of locations you want your team to go to
but surprising them with it setting up
an uber bringing a little bit of theater
to the experience
is a really great way to get the blood
pumping and to get people in a
in a in a posture of curiosity and a
posture of some excitement that they
actually can learn something from a
commune
for a project and then bring it back
into the business context i think that
the one thing i'd underscore is there's
magic to them
leaving the building there's magic to
them going to the venue
it can't be replaced by searching the
web it can't be what i can't do some
research and figure it out what's their
best it's not a best
service it's not a best practices it's
actually um
just like many of the tools we teach
inspiration and sort of um
empathy comes from the field it doesn't
come from reading about it
right and it's not a disparaging
statement to
decide that we don't have the answer yet
it's okay i think a lot of teams really
spin their wheels because they assume
if they've identified the problem that
the answer has to be somewhere in the
team
what we see is really great teams that
are really inspirational
they they declare uh defeat more quickly
in a sense they say we actually don't
know the answer
but we know how we're gonna get out of
the office we're not gonna sit here and
kind of work harder and put our heads
down and think harder
we're going to lift our heads up and say
where can we go what can we try who can
we talk to
and the teams that get out fastest end
up coming back with inspiration that
helped
great well thank you so ryan
so first of all let me thank you harry
and jeremy i really appreciate it kind
of the the
the insights that you've had from what
you've learned i really wish that
everybody had the opportunity to work
with
jerry and jeremy and perry their
enthusiasm is just infectious in my
opinion
if you as you may have heard that they
have the executive education
or they lead the executive education
over at the d school
and if you could ever see them work in
person and have had the opportunity i
think you'd really appreciate
um if you haven't gotten it from today's
presentation what they can do
but what they've done now and what i'm
really impressed in is that they've
actually taken some of what
much of what they've learned and they've
turned it into what i think is
one of our most unique courses here at
the stanford center for professional
development
so our center has been delivering online
education for something close to
45 years and we've done it typically
through a series of videos and
maybe we have a series of videos and
interactive exercises
but today what we've done what jeremy
and perry have done is actually
they've really turned it i think kind of
uh taken a new tact on it
um so first of all let me make sure that
i if i so
i don't forget i want you to if you want
more information on what i'm about to
speak to
look at that url
innovationnetwork.stanford.edu
please go visit that because you will
see how they've taken
what they've learned in doing the
workshops here and now are starting to
apply it i think to what people are
doing at their own work
you can read a little bit more here i'm
going to go into great detail and after
i go into detail i'm going to ask
jeremy and perry to speak a bit about
themselves but again
this is a new take on how we take a
workshop that we've done at stanford and
now deliver it at somebody's work
specifically what they're going to do is
they're going to take the design
thinking or part of the design thinking
concepts
and there's a great introductory video
also that you can watch and then taking
that from the design school
here that we have at stanford and taking
it to your workplace
it is a workshop so what we mean by that
is that there is detailed instructional
video
and a workbook and that you're going to
come in a team
you would have a colleague of teams and
you're going to watch those videos
and go through the workbook and what's
most important is that you're going to
apply it
right then and there to what you've
learned to your work
there is a catalyst that is part of that
so somebody is assigned at the workplace
to be
kind of the guide of the workshop and i
really would ask you again if you go to
the innovation at work.stanford.edu
website
and you look at the catalyst checklist
and here it's called the catalyst
preparation
sheet number two on setting the
expectations with the attendees
says no laptops it will be active
fast-paced structured and fun i really
think that sums up
kind of what their approach to what
learning is right they're going you're
going to learn by doing
you're going to learn because it's
interesting you're going to learn
because it's fun
uh again there's two um sessions
kind of either 60 or 90 minutes and then
there are workshops on ideation and
prototyping and if you know the
well i'll and perry to describe the
whole concept of design thinking
again um innovation
at work.stanford.edu he wanted for
information and maybe
jeremy or perry if you don't mind if you
could say if you were well first of all
we should we should
we're interesting to work with we i
think we changed our presentation 20
minutes ahead so we
ryan says we're we're also yes
um no we're we're very excited about
innovation work what we've seen
all too often is that individuals go
back and think okay how do i help my
team
i i have some new tools how do i
actually help my team
and we see this as a great resource to
to galvanize and catalyze
a team wanting to work differently what
we've seen is that
too many uh online experiences they
give some instruction and then leave it
to the student to figure out what the
heck to do with it after the instruction
happens
and so one of the things that's unique
about innovation at work is we actually
say
the first half of the session is
practicing the tools we're teaching
and then the second half is actually
applying those same tools that you just
practiced
to one of your projects at work so we
make time in the class session so to
speak
to actually use the tools of design
thinking
on your project where we continue to set
the pace and keep things moving
and give tips but you're actually
working on your work challenge
at least half of the time of the session
because we find that the biggest
disconnect or the biggest kind of drop
off is
from i'm inspired i want to work
differently to
wait how do i do that again and so we
think innovation work is a great way to
bridge the gap between practicing new
tools and applying them immediately
in your work in the context of a team
the other thing i think is pretty
interesting is rather than being an
individual on a computer
this is really about helping a team work
differently together and so the sessions
are actually designed
so that instead of just one person
answering multiple choice questions
on a computer screen you're more
oriented towards one another
and actually working on a challenge
together and every once in a while
you're referring to what's happening on
the screen
but more often you're interacting with
each other working differently together
and that we see that collaborative
dynamic as the fundamental
foundational basis for disruptive
innovation is establishing
how do we work together when the
screen's not yeah and we find the goal
is
time to application like how quickly can
we get you to apply the tools to
something in your own work because
that's where we see that it actually
sticks
you know or we learn very quickly it
doesn't and then we have to change what
we're doing
but we're very confident in testing and
sort of running the prototypes that
that's the
that's our goal is within half an hour
you're actually applying
if it's an ideation tool um prototyping
tool whatever it may be
you're applying it to a project that
matters at work yeah if you want to
if you want to sit back and consume
information this class is not for you
if you want to get out of your chair and
get you know roll up your sleeves and
dive in
to creating something this class is a
great class for you
so a couple uh one i thought was
interesting was uh one question that
came through was
um how do you sell the idea so somebody
i think i took it as someone's listening
and saying okay this is great how do i
sell it
uh to my team to my managers to whomever
so that was interesting and i think the
thing um we'd say with
um this type of work and working in this
in in this way using the tools of
innovation
you could start with yourself meaning
one thing i'd say is don't convince
anybody
go out and use this yourself on a
project or
use a direct co-worker you really have a
close relationship work with
you could actually say let's give this a
try and and get um
get a session under our belts it's a
it's always a question of cycle
you know we we weren't terrific our
first few times
using analogous techniques right we
still have learned a lot about how to
convince people how to do it but we know
that doing it getting people out and
seeing the results is the way to
reinforce
i'd rather start with a smaller team um
it's more dedicated that i trust
and get out or work with myself one time
and actually try it one time to get
confident that i can do it well
before i try to convince anybody the
other thing i'd say is
pull not push it's um i
i think that this is a great tool for
people who know they need fresh
help if if a team is oblivious to the
fact that they are
lacking in new ideas lacking in
disruptive thinking
then uh suggesting a tool like analogous
inspiration is almost an accusation yeah
and instead i think if a team is longing
for something new and saying what can we
do and is willing to try things
then being the person who brings forth
analogous inspiration as a technique is
more of a hero
than the villain who's kind of casting
stone so i wouldn't start with selling
honestly i'd start with i love barry's
idea about starting with yourself in
areas where you feel you're stuck
but then as far as working with teams
going to teams that actually
are aware that they have a need it's a
way better approach yeah
there's another question about how many
tactically how many locations to go to
or how do you how do you handle the
locations
meaning do you call ahead and i'd say
there's the answer is no
the serendipity of dropping in and in
the
in the tea shop i wonder if they had
called ahead if they wouldn't got gotten
the manager
he would ask would just answer the
questions differently then the
experience of them buying the t
and actually talking to the sales person
was exactly what they needed
they didn't need to hear the manager
about the business plan and about how
they
how many stores they have and their best
practices right
um and i would say like all this kind of
field work
they get turned down by a couple
locations they're too busy we can't talk
to you right now about our business
we've got customers in line
we don't know who you are and we're not
comfortable with it that happens
you know a certain percentage of the
time whether it's empathy interviews or
analogous
locations so i think that's part of it
is giving yourself a lot of places to go
to because some are going to yield
the results we we stuck with the ones i
oftentimes wonder if we should
we should list like they went to all
these places we're only going to tell
two so you'd understand whoever asked
that question
we maybe went to a dozen locations right
we're only talking about two because
those are the kernels that came out
yeah and i think i think the implicit in
what pear is saying is there's diversity
seeking out diversity it's not going to
an analogous inspiration location
it's see it's deciding to seek analogous
inspiration and going to five or six or
seven
and as you do spend an afternoon doing
it you start to identify themes
like the theme of transparency became
apparent very quickly as a way to make
people confident in what you say
which was uh you know it's it's it's
clear in retrospect but we didn't know
it at the time
but as you start to talk to different
locations that are across a variety of
industries you say wow this is a really
important way to do what we
have learned we need to do but don't
know how to do it um the other one was
somebody was asking there are two
questions one asks but does it work in
service businesses and the other one
asks particularly about health care
does it work in health care remember a
group that we've done something with was
working on the problem of diabetics
but they're not of of delivering um
insulin it was of changing behavior
before they became diabetic
and i remember using this technique and
we went to
i remember going to a gym and talking to
um trainers and people that sort of ran
the programs for people
and gaining inspiration i can't remember
some of the other locations but the
answer is
it applies and i think the
i remember the culture there so maybe
infer a bit of the
with the rules at least in this country
of privacy and such it seems like oh no
we can't leave the building we shouldn't
do it but
don't forget they were going to places
that don't have any privacy rules they
were going to other venues to talk about
how people change behavior right that's
what they wanted to get into and how
they do it in a positive way and get
reinforcement
and they would visit these venues to
actually they wanted i think they went
to a weight loss center they went to all
these places that they could actually
get that kind of feedback
right well you think about if for
example say you have a you have a
customer service problem you sit you see
maybe i'm just imagining in a hospital
setting
maybe it doesn't feel people uh people
inside of
the waiting room don't know what's
happening or they don't feel like they
have a connection
maybe you go to a place that's known for
customer service
maybe you go to nordstrom for example
and you seek to understand what do they
do to help the customer know i have sent
things into the
dressing room you know who is my
personal shopper who's
my connection there there are really
unexpected places where i like your
point perry that
even if you're in a industry that's kind
of cloaked in confidentiality and
secrecy
there are very simple human experiences
that you can seek out
that will illuminate different sides of
the problem and the opportunity that
maybe
you've been paying attention to yep um
one person is asking we're using the
word disruptive
i think actually a great question
because we sort of dove in and said
disrupter versus incremental innovation
i think maybe backing up and talking
about
um first of all they're they're both
amazing and
legitimate organizations need both um
i'd say
the incremental innovations we talk
about incremental innovation
it's companies that have say a product
line and the sealord folks could have
added in
and delivered very well um the hokie
product
under the blue grenadier of label and
they could have actually added that and
done really well and been
profitable and continued to grow as a
business and done that the disruptive
idea was
wow what if we what if we do a
completely different approach
meaning we're going to actually have a
marketing team we're actually going to
do a logo we're going to do a separate
sales pitch we're going to do separate
um point of purchase
something hadn't been done before so all
these sort of new assets
a fundamentally different approach um
and that's how we break it up i think of
it more as
as incremental versus disruptive um one
builds on the success and continues to
sort of riff but with a
with a narrower set of of things you're
changing or variables you're changing
the other one is willing to bring in
disruptive ideas are almost like you're
approaching the
the customer segment differently or the
market entirely differently
um how often does a team use this kind
of technique
or i think that was the um
often do you recommend yeah how often do
you recommend i think again it comes
down to that self diagnosis
they one i think we've we've learned
with our teams
it's good to get out of the building and
put energy into it
and we can kind of gauge it based on
energy with our experience of sort of
doing this kind of work i think in in
internal teams in organizations
i think it's really useful to get out of
the building for this type of thing
so i'd say if you're if it's that slide
that says uh
new ideas but same old brainstorm or
something there's a slide in our deck
that says that if that's sort of your
attitude heading into your
team like we got this great idea of oh
boy we're going to come up with this
gotta just get you know sort of building
i think it's a great way to put energy
into the team so i gauge it with energy
so i think that's let's see what else we
got that's come in
i think we have tougher just one last
question seems like a great way to
protect the team from group think
agree yes yes
okay well there you go there's our last
question and answer
for that i want to thank everybody for
attending please remember that this has
been recorded so if you missed any
portion we'll be sending a link to that
we again appreciate your participation
jeremy perry thank you so much